I mean you go ah morning prayers in
buiiet the language spoken in this part
of Siberia and this is the Republic of
Buryatia sanctuary Lake Baikal it's of
the world's deepest freshwater reservoir
a UNESCO World Heritage Site and a
symbol of Russia's vast natural
landscapes irina tangle nova has been up
since 5 p.m. here on superiors holy
mountain cut boron today she's meeting
with fellow believers shamans like
herself the shamans of Lake Baikal
Borja mountain is the ritual site for
the age-old poet culture
like oh it's a beautiful Lake Baikal is
our holy lake this is where we gather
our strength are there a lot of shamans
here like again yes up to a hundred we
come here because thirteen hottas live
here our gods and spirits they are
strong and wish to show us their power
they appear so as not to miss the
spirits arrival I had off right away
with arena to the location where the
indigenous peoples of siberia halted the
so-called international shaman
conference is present at the start of
the conference
she knows the customs of spirit
incantation yesterday news post-crisis
fearful for the buddha when the spirits
descend to earth they let their radiancy
rise up again through the birch trees
thank you when we shamans touch the
birch branches we ourselves become part
of the universe good web shades
all-ireland
1,500 people live here most abort
who she used to be a Soviet fishing
village today its residents make their
living from tourism its visitors are
mainly from Russia and Asia back to the
shamans Irina is preparing the offerings
welcome studies first we have milk then
decided I place poly which is a mixture
of biscuits chocolates and gingerbread
then we have a Sulha
or candle this combination brings luck
and prosperity technical than you would
with me here we have fought it we faced
it in the direction we think the spirits
will come from we also have placed money
and cigarettes here in case of the
ghosts one to smoke with you the wind
picks up in the early afternoon events
our the spirits analysis of their
presence with a shaman speak in German
to show their willingness to read them
the slams fate is sealed a gift to the
gods the animal is killed with practiced
skill now it's finally time for Irina to
put herself in a trance
they begin with the dance among the
birch trees where the shamans receive
spirits and light of them into their
bodies
the spirits arena believes that the
spirit of the late rent are the resides
inside her body she sings with her
grandmother's voice well my grandmother
was here and gave me luck in my work as
a shaman after the ceremony the birches
are burnt I learn that the ash will they
catch now will bring health and
happiness
the highlight of the evening is the
washing ritual where the participants
separated by gender are washed with the
water that the lamb was cooked in these
ancient spiritual practices are meant to
expel all evil from my body whether I
believe it or not which is they do
passionately I wish you health that is
very important you are an explorer
you must learn a lot in life I want to
mediate want to help others so we all
can be happy okay shamanism is one of
the oldest religious traditions in
Siberia
it's culture is still alive and well on
the sacred ohan islands on lake baikal